ciao amici sono con gli altri amici a 1
e ciccio l'altro e thomas stiamo per
giocare bene possiamo partire sempre ok
grazie grazie all'ok bene promette bene
sta per rai quindi la cosa più difficile
della giornata l'abbiamo fatta e ora
possiamo andare siccome io gioco
fornetto una volta al mese se va bene ho
visto che hanno fatto il deserto palmeto
paradisi a ma non ci andiamo mai
no no c'è da un volto di gente dai fammi
vedere come andiamo molto bello anch'io
dai raga forza let's go
dobbiamo fare i ninja moderni dove dove
le persone io te l'ho detto c'è una
botta di gente che oggi comunque ma c'è
molta gente ma state tranquilli andrà
tutto bene e ti rompo le palle per
andarci comunque questo il problema
e poi mi son mille persone tra la strada
mi sorprendo di me stessa
salve eccolo sopra non sono stato io
vedo vedo
è la propria vita ora vedo più volte lui
va bene adesso cosa facciamo programmi
né le magnum è finito il gioco ipa
abbiamo vinto ciao da giorgio vero che
li rocket linga del ragazzo il 16 di
vita e non lo so ma va accettato
l'opposto che male aiuto amici grazie
se qualcuno sta costruendo sopra vino e
la cosa non mi assicura tantissimo
purtroppo fa pure le granate scherzi
vabbè è stata simpatica come prima
tentativo guarda che già il fatto che
non sia morti tutti iniziano chi ci sta
una propositiva
[Musica]
la re
va bene basta è altissimo e lo giuro
ecco questo è ancora di più perché scusa
amico mio ti voglio tanto bene numero
cosa ma uno è notato due sulle note che
sia pugni
sarei preso a pugni quello proprio ove
sono materiali non lo vedo non lo vedo
dove i poeti hai guardato positivo sto
per morire un colpo dice edizione non ho
usato bene era stanco il personaggio
dove centro no dovevo morire e guarda
mentre non ci stai
si no va bene spingo io faccio io zitti
vieni ciccio dove è quello basali solo
perché ho cambiato ma no sto facendo qua
via via
guardali che giocatori questa qui sono
sinistra cosa significa questa in lotta
ma cos'ha gesù cosa vedo ma cosa succede
nel mondo aiuto amici a cose o persone
ma cos'è voglio di farlo subito
ma venne altro avveniva tra l'altro così
che senso ha questa cosa guarda guarda
non ha mai funzionato lo nuovo file però
va bene abitato la fa non so se rai
anche male mio dio sotto controllo amici
questa è la prova di guida
[Applauso]
ma comme faccio senza successo
occhio ai ragazzi stacco sei morto
questa e l'istruttore di guida allora
abbiamo stando all'esame che dispiace
andiamo borgo bislacco agata questa casa
di bordeaux bisogno perché sorridendo
con borgo bis ma perché so già che
morirai casa blu caso di the deep e la
rubino la rossa nel gruppo aveva
rossoblù rossa per fare ti poni in gesso
thank you free bari for one million e
thank you so much sarà palustri for one
million alla cane ma chi è crescere ma
capisco questo non lo avevo ancora visto
tra l'altro a cosa serve ma se non c'è
pugliese il carrello è forte come sa
cosa vedo e completa cos'è è comprato la
lattuga supermercato hammami a fool di
salata vado giù si vola mario definitivo
il bellissimo attacchiamo andiamo a si
fonda solo io sarei avuto puoi fare
questa cosa è una bellissima poi ci
tuffiamo giudice addio mondo che bel mi
piace un sacco
bisogna che sia gente che sulla pianta
fa
costruito con cura un regalo
cioè come so giocare bene a questo gioco
come come mirò bene
sono andato giù vabbè partito pezzo di
uno schifoso l'ater prg ior e incassa
compatti per trovare le casse casson
bolla di quello che non sono
abbiate fatto a dare ai cittadini e non
ci vincerà ci arriva insieme non
facciamo due cifre di quoziente
intellettivo dove sono sti qua dietro al
mento casa di verdini verso di me vadano
mentre un colpo con los carmi liam e dai
se sono scarso fis troppo 6 scarl
grazie prego ragazzi ci penso io
i nuovi quattro tensione lui pero io ti
sparano si sparano ho vinto io sono
forte alla detto albero è lui la serivi
in top
quand'è top2 noto top trail torto 4.2
facciamo due gol si toglie la mafia fra
live figlia moglie la foto la metto pure
nel video
mancano quattro persone con la puoi
stemperarlo se la fecola fermo solo due
quale giu controllo no lo slide si
chiama con ossia un lanciagranate con
l'ance parate un lancia sempre quando
gli spara volo si gira e mice ma che fai
stili dove è più il mi fa così firme è
più il che mi metto qua nessuno sa dove
sono top tre ragazzi ho vinto
tokyo questo gioco è top2 ai trials
bravo le promesse non promesse e berti
aspetta aspetta
andiamo per i telai non credo che tu sia
in live tom pace a vere e proprie
allora sembrava una una promessa da
promessa
no
non ce lo scorso anno faceva come ma
come fai a stare a luglio c a dubai e
questo va meglio nella baia di certo
devo giocare
complimenti preparatevi ricaricate
l'arma tenetevi pronti io la mia bella
pistola non può nulla arma carica e
pronta a sparare veloce veloce carico e
pronto stato ucciso io non ci sono oggi
ma perché non ci sono l'annuncio fondi e
poi non per nulla o stronzi ucciso con
la pistola sono stato bravissimo non ha
mai ucciso quando fai pronto
ingegneristica lega dietro la rete di
pietra per cambio che li ammazza dove
scorre di pietra no ma guarda che forse
allora dietro in cui dietro alla
macchina di lamentata della dietro è
trovato
no non è qua dietro ci sei sicuro vorrà
bene salvo forse con questa canzoncina
esce fuori
[Musica]
eccola lì ma guarda guarda come abbiamo
fatto che trovavi sopra con la piastra e
tram ha fatto una tattica perfetta come
hai fatto notare che non è costruito
alcune costruito entrai la ex imola vado
tipo harry potter tra belle da bari
quella buona è una più scudo vogliamo
raggiungere mano va perché mi separarli
farlo subentrare come stop mancando
lanciando franco è un branco cinese il
signore raccontiamo le storie di quando
eravamo giovani di una volta ero un
pezzo di pietra che mi hanno scolpito
sono così per tutti e tre si va a
vincerla
vai se lasciamo che si attacchino
dollari loro e poi non arriviamo per
ultimi potremo vincere e possiamo farla
fratelli più correttamente non stiamo
creando chiusura di venerdì fortuna
rocco four four
bravo la anni
rimasto un team siamo 2 contro 3 1 è
toccato a cava cà vuole salire con delle
scale non sono capace
il loro arrivo dalle aree dentro di te
dove la strada che appena fatto la
strada capi da parte di tre ditte aiuto
minuti è quello che amo locato io né due
fasi vista tanto non aveva niente di
vita o c'e la seggiovia nostra bene però
che cazzo scappa scappa non va va bè
ragazzi so perché mi è piaciuto siamo
fortissimi a ford nate grazie mille alla
mia presenza è niente se non ci fossi
stato io
cugat beh ragazzi sbagliato ho sbagliato
l'altro
[Musica]